[موسيقى]
مرضى السرطان من الاطفال شمال غرب سوريا
نجوا من الزلزال ولم ينجوا من تداعياته
بعد ان اغلقت تركيا عبور عموم مرضى
السرطان الى اراضيها بسبب الضغط على
المستشفيات الطفل هو عبد القادر عوض يبلغ
من العمر 12 عاما خانه سرطان سركومه واصيب
بشلل جزئي وفقد الحركه بعد ان توقف عن
تلقيه جرعات الضروريه لعلاجه 25 يوم متاخر
على الجرعات ورجعت الوجع لاجره
صار لي ست شهور الماضيه نهائيا والد عبد
القادر ناشد المعنيين فتح معبر باب الهوى
لانقاذ طفله قبل فوات الاوان
اليوم قبل بكره
يعني
مناشد كل شيء بايده الامر من وزاره الصحه
من وزاره الصحه العالميه
وزاره الصحه التركيه انه ياسرنا الامر
اليوم قبل بكره لانه الامر ما عاد يتحمل
يعني هاي الورم هذا شايفينه هذا بايام صار
معنا ونحن هذا قاطعين هاي المده سنه ثلاثه
شهور ما شفناها
بابتسامه من الامل لعبد القادر امنيه
وحيده الدخول الى تركيا ومتابعه علاجه
ادخل على تركيا وكم من علاجه
فقط محاسن حضاره العربيه
[موسيقى]